à à
Xin chào các bạn
Mình công nhận là giờ hơi kiểu thay đổi
liên tục nóng lúc 7 rưỡi lúc thì
7:50 lúc 8 giờ
À thỉnh thoảng thế nên là thời ra cũng
hơi bị chắc là
anh cũng hơi khó chịu với các bạn một tí
đó là thế kiểu là
anh không đúng giờ lắm không ạ
Các bạn sẽ không vào đúng giờ các bạn sẽ
bị hỏng
nhưng mà Đấy hóa cho Hồng nghe mình tâm
sự thôi chứ không phải là hóa học của
cái học thì vẫn đúng 8 giờ đúng không ạ
mình thì
cho sự bởi vì mình có nuôi con cún ra
giờ giấc sinh hoạt của mình làm à em hỏi
khi đã là đã là kiểu dặn á
áo kiểu dạng ở sinh hoạt thất thường rồi
Cho cậu ăn ngủ loạn hết cả lên thì con
bị ảnh hưởng bởi vậy con Con Cún nữa vì
con cú nó thường hay xua nó kiểu mình
mình đang thuê nhà chung với 11 ông bạn
nữa
là nó cứ sủa ông bạn thấy đậu xanh cho
bạn sống ở tầng trên cứ sủa kiểu cứ đi
qua nó xua
con gà con con này giống phốc Nhưng mà
mình cấy vào nó bị ngu đứa kia nó không
nhận diện được mùi và nó bị cận thì phải
cứ sủa cái chính mình chứ nói ông kia
chú chim cứu khoa học
à Bạn Phương Linh Phương Linh này Phương
Linh mọi không nhỉ Hình như là dưới vì
mình mới xem lại
anh bình luận điện thấy Phương Linh này
em thay đổi ảnh đại diện với cảnh ở
à à
em nhắc nhớ mình có hứa với bạn này một
cái
tôi sẽ bật mí cho mày ông sau
Ừ nếu mà bạn thấy đạt được
à à
À hôm nay sẽ hợp với rách mình còn mấy
cái MI mày ghét hay phết
mà trong người ông xem
cái chính tôi từng đăng của cái gạch rồi
Thế mi mấy
ừ ừ
ở Milan ý Nhựt nó tương tự chúng ra
Swift thì méo đủ biết được nó có thể đã
làm như thế nào tôi có thể My về cách nó
là
ừ ừ
à à
ở đây đây tôi có tôi tưởng đại bi mềm
huyền thoại này
Ừ
tôi có 99 vấn đề sau đó tôi dùng dưới
cách Tôi có 100 vấn đề để kiểu thế
thì các bạn sẽ biết được là kiểu hoa
ghét nó có thể khiến cho mình thêm vấn
đề nào
ở Nghệ An chỉ là người ta thường anh
nghĩ đến việc dùng rách để tìm ra giải
pháp nên thừa ra đôi khi Chính nó là thứ
cậu tạo tạo nên vấn đề
Nghe kể chuyện nha ở đầu tiên bạn ở một
vấn đề này gái của giải pháp này bạn ở
tận hai vấn đề
Ừ nó bảo là số nhiều lý cách nói chính
là les hay hối ạ
cái kệ dễ
anh
nói thế nhưng mà nó giống kiểu ra Speed
Thôi thì nhiều người dùng với nhiều
người chết nhưng mà nhưng mà như người
vẫn dùng
Ừ nó nó nó là kiểu bị ngược cái hồi
trước xem cái
xổ số người số lập trình viên ghét 1 thứ
gì đó nhất
Việt kiều đông đảo lập trình viên ghét
thì đỏ nhất gấp nhận thấy có vẻ ra suy
trong ấy có phải giá hoa này Vân sau đó
người ta mới xem lại thì hóa ra do cộng
đồng người rất là đông thì nữa thấy số
người ghét nó nó cũng đông kiểu thế
Ừ nếu hình dung kiểu do nhiều người dùng
có nhiều người khó chịu chứ Giả sử với
là có nhiều với những ngôn ngữ lập trình
và trái biết đến cả thì là là chuyện có
người ghét đúng ạ ạ
cho nên làm với ông đừng có để con số
Đánh Lừa mấy ông nhìn thấy đống meme ở
đây rất như nhưng sẽ nhiệt quay Chắc là
cái ngôn ngữ bị ghét bỏ nhiều lắm Vân
Vân đúng gọn
khi họ cây cái lượng người ghét nó có
thể chiếm 28 không ạ thì chẳng có ngày
hai mươi phần trăm của cái của cái số
người ghét đầu tư của cộng đồng đấy đối
ngoại là lớn quá ra là trông có vẻ nhiều
vai trưởng như thế này ngọn
anh nói chung đề để các bạn với qua được
rách nó có thể như thế nào trên mạng thì
đầy đầy hướng dẫn cái Tôi từng chỉ cho
mấy ông mấy ông cận nên nhớ những cái
khái niệm này khi trao Google này nhất
là các bạn thêm chữ Totoro nếu mà các
bạn thật sự là không hiểu
tôi rồi tôi như biết sai lầm nhưng khớp
tô lúc nào
cho
đúng rồi chúng tôi rồi
ờ ờ ờ
à Còn nếu các bạn biết thêm nhiều cái
giống như thêm trước 101 cũng được 101 à
đối với bên nước ngoài nó sẽ là da cơ
bản
thích cái gì Nếu thay vì tiêu đề của kia
tôi đấy lập trình quét 101 18 sẽ hiểu
được là hạn chế nó giữ cơ bản như thế
nào
và hoặc là mấy ông để khiến chữ chít
chít
chít chít thì nhiều không chơi game này
mày không biết cheat là theo kiểu là da
lợn nó loa kẹo kéo dạng lại
khách nó kiểu cậu biết à
ai biết trước một cái gì đó Vân Vân Vân
ừ ừ tôi là tôi thích sai cả
không sao chào gù lên nó vẫn kiểu gợi ý
đúng cho mấy ông mà bỏ qua đi
và cái nói chung là chít là theo cửa là
nó gian lận theo cửa là nó mánh khóe
kiểu của Thế con xít Đó là kiểu ôxit nó
nó nó Nó kiểu nó nằm trong một cái bảng
excel vậy và ông kết hợp như thế này
chẳng hạn tôi thử tra viên béo nhớ chứ
hết
đó thôi mấy ông ấn vào hình ảnh nó trở
lại
Lê Hoàng đã sẽ ra một cái bảng đầy đủ
Anh Không những mà cú pháp mà còn đôi
khi kèm gỡ cả chú thích ví dụ cho mấy
ông như thế này chị tóm gọn trong một
cái ảnh đó
Ê mày ông thử tra không phải mỗi đấy vừa
mọi cái giống như là HTML này Sao ngồi
ra Swift này nó ra đây đủ những cái bộ
thẻ chẳng ạ thật thứ thứ xét này chẳng
hạn
nó sẽ ra như này
ở đó
em thấy được khai sáng không Khi mà béo
học lập trình cái này không áp dụng cho
mỗi ngôn ngữ lập trình nhé Nếu nó dụng
nên rất nhiều cái kiểu gì cũng sẽ có
nhiều người làm chữ chế cho nó rồi cái
Vì thế nên mới bạn ạ tôi dậy cho mấy ông
Dần dần nó việc biết cách sử dụng Google
mà nóng lạnh Ok làm chua ngọt bài hôm
nay chúng ta sẽ tôi tôi có ghi ở trong
này nó là ờ
có tác dụng của nó nó ngon
Ừ đợi có một tí thôi trả lời xét phát
sốt nhắn tin tôi làm việc cả cuối tuần
Chính xác là sếp của tội làm việc cuối
tuần
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ ok Nói chung bây giờ bắt đầu buổi học
nha
à à
ở buổi học hình như tôi vừa nói đó là
mình sẽ
ở đầu tiên biết được ghét dùng để làm gì
kết hợp với việc là
mình sẽ học rách cả buổi hôm nay sẽ đi
học với gạch thì các bạn sẽ thấy là
vì nó có thể nhắn một buổi là không đủ
cho gạch Nhưng mà cũng có thể dài nếu mà
biết rồi vì về cơ bản để tôi chỉ nói lại
toàn bộ những cái cơ bản của Jack Tôi
không nói tí gì ở nâng cao cả thì đầu
tiên để mà hiểu gạch dùng để làm gì thì
trước hết là nó kết hợp với jess dùng để
làm gì đã Hình như tôi từng nói đó là
mấy ông cuối cái cái ra Swift này tôi
dậy trong bé ông chị đủ đủ để cho bé Ông
làm cái này nó ra và a date from thật là
sao nghĩa là
số bài toán ở đây nhá đó là mấy ông sẽ
làm ở cái form để mà điền thông tin ra
sửa điền thông tin đăng ký ở ạ đúng ngọn
sau đó thì cho người dùng Điền Điền ABC
Điền caffein đăng ký nhé Còn đăng ký này
con khỉ các bạn sẽ thường anh có gì ạ Có
họ tên email
mật khẩu đúng rồi xô ngồi số điện thoại
được ạ trà xử lý nhất cơ bản như thế nó
ngọn đưa toàn bộ những cái này sau đó
thì đẩy lên trên con xe vô rồi con
server là sự xử lý nó lưu lại thông tin
của người dùng đã nhật điểm gì để mà đem
ra xử ra đây mà để cho người dùng đăng
nhập vào đúng không ạ
Ừ cái thì trước khi lưu lại thông tin
lại thì nó rất là nguy hiểm theo kiểu
người dùng nhập mình tay tinh cũng lưu à
Thì thấy rất là sai hoặc à kiểu để kiểm
tra cho người dùng kiểu cảnh báo người
dùng Giả sử email người dùng nhập nhiều
người dùng tôi từng gặp rất nhiều người
theo kiểu là kiểu dụng là Long tự nhiên
thay vì ai còn nhớ anh người ta quên
người ta gõ như này chả ngán ra bị thiếu
cái khe cắm cái gì đó đúng ạ thậm chí là
gõ nhầm chấm thành dấu phẩy những ai
chẳng nhãn nó bị lỗi Đúng không xong
người dùng cứ thắc bát à Rõ ràng ta nhập
Đúng rồi Nhưng mà giỡn ra mà khi mà
người dùng nhập người dùng có người kiểm
tra lại đâu nhưng không bao giờ được khi
vọng người dùng nhập đúng không bao giờ
được hi vọng
anh điều đấy bởi vì thực sự thì người
dùng là một cái gì đó mà vãi chưa
và
con người thì luôn có sai sót nên thành
ra là người dùng Nhập nó sẽ ra loạn thì
Jack
Ừ nó hỗ trợ không phải đi kiếm không
phải là để làm cái vụ
ý là bắt được đúng sai như thế mà ra
Swift mày đó thằng bắt để trường hợp
đúng hay sai còn J AK là chỉ để kiểm tra
xem một thứ nó nhập vào nó có nó có khớp
hay không thôi
ở đây gic đề kiểm tra duyệt và tìm
đi tìm kiếm những thứ hợp lệ kiểu thế
trong một chuỗi
ký tự trở lại dịch ra cậu lý thuyết nó
là như thế tức là sao
ờ đâm chỉ là ông vừa rồi đấy Giả sử lá
có một cái đoạn email đúng ạ
Có một đợi email tôi tôi gõ phẳng như
thế này thì mới ông nhìn dung được nó
lên mê luôn tại sao ạ Tại sao Tại sao
tôi gõ như này thì ông cũng hình dung nó
là email đúng ạ
a a
b c
như thế này
xy&z nhà Nếu cũng hình dung này là email
phải Sao ba Cái này nó có gì giống nhau
có chị Loan nói chưa
nhà hay đi làm
tôi có những cái gì giống nhau ở đây với
ông nhận diện nó là một email
a a còng à còn gì để tôi nhập mũi còn
như này thì nó ra đi Mèo không khóc đúng
nó gọi
em có cộng và chấm nhá Đây đây là mù
Email gì mấy ông bảo đây là muốn email
đúng không
Đã thế lại nhầm rồi
nhà hả Ai còn hỏi chấm nó biến thành
email rồi Chết Đâu Thế là có giờ
có còn tên miền ở đây thế này mới email
đúng không
à à
Ừ đúng rồi bạn Cường Văn kia nó về 3
trường Trần hơn tí không ạ nhưng mà Đấy
nghĩa là bé ông đang bảo dần việc là
tăng trước phải có một cái gì đó đúng
không ạ mình trước có một lần thứ tự gì
đó chuyển ngày Nếu ạ ABC ạ sau đó thì
phải có dấu Hoa còn không ạ sau đó là
một tên miền không ạ tên miền bản chất
là tên miền của mấy ông cũng cũng bản
chất Nó là một loại ký tự gì đó là sự
vẫn là a b c sôi phải kèm theo người dấu
chấm nữa xong rồi đằng sau Nó có thể là
ABC tiếp Chán thế đấy theo cửa đơn giản
bởi vì nhiều nơi thì nó sẽ còn theo cậu
có cả số ở trong tên miền và dần đúng
không ạ ạ
Ừ đấy thì mày không thấy cái tô vừa hỏi
thì mếu không lại bắt được trường hợp
đẳng trước này nó có những trường nào gì
xảy ra và cái tên miền nó có những
trường hợp gì xảy ra cái thứ của mấy ông
chắc chắn ở đây giống như lúc đầu mà ông
nói thì mấy ông chị chắc chắn việc là nó
có cong cùng lắm là thêm có thêm dấu
chấm động ngoại đấy thì cái này nó sẽ là
tính cách nó lại kiểu mình sẽ kết hợp
chỗ mà theo kiểu dạng như thế này tăng
trước nó là có thể toàn bộ là chữ từ a
đến z trở lại và không phải là chữ viết
hoa thì mình sẽ là a đến z như thế này
cái khái niệm Ừ từ a đến z sôi kết hợp
với ngoặc vuông như thế này để làm gì
Nghĩa làm chị là
cái cái
chữ cái từ A đến Z Mình sẽ lấy 1 ký tự
trong phạm vi từ a đến z nó sẽ là dùng
ngoặc vuông như thế này để lấy một ký tự
trong trong cái đấy Và nếu bây giờ sử
các bạn muốn lấy nhiều ký tự
ở trong từ a đến z thì các bạn sẽ thêm
dấu như thế này thành chú dấu cộng nữa ạ
nhưng mà đỡ nhau tôi để mua như thế này
thì mới ông sẽ chẳng hiểu cái gì cả tôi
sẽ ghi thảm họa học ở trên trang
regex101.com để mấy ông xe ok
anh béo để ý ở ở bên này mày không để ý
cho tôi về cái
mát information and
thì nó sẽ hiển thị xa những cái mà nó
thỏa mãn này và nó giải thích trông béo
ngoài rất tiện tôi sẽ copy mới kể
Ê mấy ông sẽ phải luôn biết được là cái
nào đúng cái nào sai ở đây
xe
tải đầu tiên thì tôi gõ từ a đến z mà
ông thấy chẳng hiện tượng gì xảy ra cả
bởi vì Nghi như thế này thì nó lại không
hiểu từ a đến z đâu ạ mình phải cho nó
vào trong cái mặt vua như này chi mấy
ông sẽ thấy là nó đang bôi có vẻ là tất
cả các tất cả các chữ của mình từ anh
ghét rồi nhớ nó đang bôi rồi ra chữ một
chữ một đống ạ chứ nó không liền nhau để
ví dụ chữ Long là cắt thành chữ L oreal
này đúng ạ để mà mình muốn nó lấy liền
cả một cụm cùng 1 lúc thì mình sẽ có
khái niệm dùng dấu cộng nha
tôi mọc chữ giây đi nhé đó khi mấy ông
sẽ thấy là
À mà thôi cứ để lại không ra thì mày ông
sẽ thấy đó là
anh thấy nó đang lấy chữ Long này sao
lấy chữ Gmail này thôi lấy chữ con này
không ạ như nó không lấy thêm chữ là nó
không đầy kệ ta còn đúng ạ Ừ thì yêu
mình cách cái mình đầy a còn mình chỉ
dành cái chất cong này thôi ông ạ từ
tiếp theo gì nữa mình gõ thêm chữ Gmail
đúng ạ Mình gọi chữ mail nghe không được
mấy ông thấy
gọi chữ gmail như này thì nó lại không
lấy chị ra gồm cả ABC kiểu đồ ngoại đứng
chị ạ Thế bây giờ mình một lấy cả toàn
bộ những thế này thì mình lại từ A Z
đóng ngoặc
từ là thì ghé tiệm này rồi lại dấu cộng
Thế mày thì cái cậu này cậu này tôi sẽ
giải thích cho mấy ông cộng nó là gì
cộng trong lý gạch nó sẽ không hiểu Nó
là cậu nó không hiểu Nó dấu cộng mà nó
sẽ hiểu là
Ừ nó là tôi tôi sẽ ghi theo dạng như này
cho mày ông dễ hiểu nhé cháu làm min là
một và mắt là vô cực
cái cái nin là gì quan trọng Khởi My và
cả mắc là gì Nghĩa là ám chỉ là chăm cái
mặc vua mày này mình phải có ít nhất có
ít nhất là một một ký tự lấy trong ô
vuông này và
mắc là vô cực Tức là mình có thể lấy bao
nhiêu ký tự trong ngoặc vuông này cũng
được đó nghĩa là chữ trong ngoặc vuông
này Ít nhất nó phải có một giống như
trong trường hợp này các bạn thấy tôi
thử Xóa lại đi nhé
Ừ nếu không thấy à Nếu mà tôi để như này
nhà
Để như này thôi thì nó sẽ lại có khái
niệm là lấy một ký tự nằm trong từ a đến
z tức là xa nếu mà như thế này
nó lấy một ký tự nặng nằm trong gì gì đó
thì tức làm Nhi là một và mắc cũng là
một
và nó không hề ở cái dòng chỉ có a còng
hai a còng chấm này nó làm gì có chữ thử
anh siro đúng không ạ thì nó không lấy
gì cả Còn trong trường hợp này nó lấy
1111 này đúng không ạ nhưng bờ tôi cho
nó dấu cộng như thế này tắm thì nó sẽ mi
là một và mắc và vụ Vô Cực nên Hay là cứ
cái đoạn nào có chuỗi
ô chữ thì nó sẽ lấy nó không ạ
ờ ờ tiếp theo là mình sẽ cho mình mình
sẽ cho là a còn nó như vậy tôi nói sao
lại từ a đến z này
thôi mình lại cập này để lấy bởi trong
trường hợp giờ sử Tôi có một cái email
dạng như này à
ở đó thì nó sẽ không lấy đúng ạ Nó sẽ
không lời kể Lâm A còng tay và bắt buộc
sau đó phải có ký tự thì nó mới lấy đấy
ạ tiếp theo là bé ông muốn có dấu chấm
nữa để bọn tôi thử chấm ôm Bống xem nhé
Ừ ok chấm Cái này chả gì xảy ra tạm thời
Thế không ạ sợ tôi An rét em ạ a đến
z sao lại cập như ai chẳng hạn nó gọn
nếu mà tại sao tự nhiên tôi mà chấm ở
đây như thế này chấm ở đây nó có vấn đề
đấy ạ Chưa hỏi chấm nơi cho vui này đâu
Tôi thử ví dụ cho mấy ông nhé tôi không
đổi này chấm Có để nó dấu gạch ngang
nghe đi
khi mang thai có nói gì xảy ra không ạ
Cứ để nó là xấu à
ah còn nữa cũng được đổi nó là như này
cũng được đổi nó thành nhưng lại được
chấm ở đây nếu mà Mấy ông gõ nó thẳng là
dấu chấm như này thì nó bị sai để trong
túi rách chấm nói thay thế cho mọi ký tự
đây nó sẽ là mắt any vector vọng nghĩa
nó thay thế cho mọi thứ tự thành ra là
kiểu bây giờ mấy ông muốn hiểu chấm nó
chỉ đơn giản là chấm thôi
có giống thì mình sẽ phải dùng cái sọc
chéo nhé để hạ sốt chéo như này bể nó
cái khái niệm trong lập chỉnh khi một
chục chéo trước một cái gì đó thì nó sẽ
để mà
à à AF nó kiểu dạng là hết Nó là ký tự
bình thường tức là nó sẽ chẳng có cái
tác dụng gì ngoài cái kiểu nó là chỉ nó
cả bởi vì giống như vừa nãy tôi nói về
vụ dấu cộng này hai dấu ngoặc vuông này
mấy ông cũng thay thế bởi vì nó làm một
cái kiểu nó nó vừa là ký tự nó vừa có
một cái ý nghĩa riêng của nó đúng ạ Chứ
không phải một ký tự bình thường nữa thì
cái giấu hoặc gạch chéo này để ép cho nó
thành kính tự bình thường Và thậm chí
nếu mấy ông muốn giờ xử làm Nếu muốn có
dấu gạch chéo ở đây trở lại như thế này
giả sử Giả sử Thế thôi nhá Khi mấy ông
lại có thể là cái chéo gạch chéo như này
để chắc chắn nó là ký tự để chém đúng
không ạ
ở
đó đây bay vừa rồi mới chỉ cũng là cơ
bản một tí về à Ông kia nói về vụ
chéo nơ vải chéo rồi chào Tây đúng không
cái chén cái chéo mà kết hợp với chữ như
thế thì nó lại mày nghĩa khác ở trong
back nên có
à Tôi đang nói được là gạch chéo ép nó
ký sự bình thường khi nó là cái chèo ký
tự Còn với chữ thì nó lại khác
anh cứ bình tĩnh Nhã Okay ở đây
mày mì Ông vừa thấy đây là mới chỉ đang
bề mua cua và gạch các bạn Nhưng mà thực
ra là nó vẫn còn thêm nhiều cá yếu tố
nữa bởi vì trong trong Email đấy thì nó
còn có cả số có cả dấu chấm
Anh nghịch dưới nấu ăn
Ừ đúng đúng nhỉ cách dưới có mà đúng
không gạch ngang rồi Mình nhớ không có
bệnh nha như có cái gì dưới
em thật sự email của bạn với dụng lại
à à khi yêu em ạ ạ
hàng
triệu trái tim tan vỡ
31 triệu trái tim tan vỡ
hả Còn
Lại Đây này
kiểu nhà Ờ cái này là
cái này câu của ông JV Evermind đó không
không phải tôi tự nghĩ ra đâu là thì giả
sử như thế này
em có một cái email như thế này đúng
không ạ Chồng cũng có vẻ hợp lệ thì
Ừ thì
phải dùng những cách để mà nhận diện ra
một vì đây là một email hợp lệ đúng
không ạ thì nó như thế nào
ừ ừ
Ừ
thì per Minute cái cái vừa rồi mình áp
dụng đúng hết tất cả trên những cái dưới
lại không đúng không ạ Thì bây giờ mình
làm thế nào để dưới này đúng không ạ Vì
ông sẽ để ở đây nó sẽ bao gồm những cái
gì đó là nó có gạch dưới này nó có cả
một này 1 đến 9 chẳng ạ đúng không ạ
Ừ
thì cách để mà làm nó đỡ giản là mà đơn
giản nữa nhé đó là theo kiểu là nếu
không có thể ghi thảm hại trong cái
ngoặc vuông này là từ 1 đến 9 thận chết
từ 0 đến 9 ý nghĩa có nhập được chọn số
không đi như này và mấy ông một lấy ở cá
sấu gạch dưới đúng không ạ thì mới ông
cho thêm kịch rửa như thế này tôi thêm
cái giàu quá như thế này chắc thằng nọ
nó là cái đấy đôi khi được ra không cần
đâu rồi cánh dưới nó không ý nghĩa gì cả
nhưng mà để này cho nó nó hiểu nó chắc
chắn nó là Cái dưới là sự nếu người ông
không biết đó thì nó sẽ ra như thế này
không ạ đi
à à
Ừ cái này Tôi nhấn mạnh lại không phải
do tôi nghĩ ra lắm nhé không Nếu không
phải bảo tôi ăn cắp bản quyền í
ở đó thì đây Đây là lý khách mời ông sẽ
thấy da dưới nách Nó có tác dụng là nó
nó sẽ nhập những cái Nếu mà Mấy ông chưa
học qua di cách mà không nhìn cái chỗ
làm nó chả hiểu nó cái gì cả đúng hạn
bây giờ một ông nó gió mới vào xem mới
học sẽ nhìn thấy loại này chả hiểu nó gì
cả nhưng tự nhiên nó lại khiến cho bôi
bôi sáng đấy dòng dừa như này không ạ
thì mới ông sẽ giữ hình dung được A cái
đoạn mày có gia dụng là tìm kiếm một cái
chuỗi văn bản đó nằm trong cái đoạn dài
nhé Đông ạ ạ
Ừ ok không ạ à
Ừ thì mệnh mày ông sẽ hiểu được lấy gạch
có tác dụng là kiểu để bàn như thế đề
thi thì biết nó không chỉ có mỗi những
cái này không chỉ có mỗi như thế này tôi
sẽ giải thích nốt cho mấy ông những cái
như sau
đầu tiên thì nó sẽ có khái niệm nó là
như này là sử tôi sẽ đền mua nó ra kiểm
một mười Nga thì nó sẽ làm nhim1 mắt
người
Các bạn nhớ lại vụ Mimax tôi vừa nói
trên không ạ Tức làm chỉ ra đằng trước
nó ví dụ là sự là đây tôi có
ờ ờ
a a a đến z nó làm in 1 mắt 10 nghe đi
giờ tôi có một chỗ như thế này
xe tải mẹ ông thầy đó đến cái đoạn này
tự nhiên màu nó khác gì đoạn này nó đến
10 rồi nó ngừng ngọn đoạn này nó nó lại
tách ra một hai ông ạ
Ừ nó tách làm hai đây mày Ông thấy như
này không sao nhưng đến 10 hoặc tách làm
hai Bởi vì khi đến 10 rồi nó sẽ không
nằm trong cái a z này nữa nó tách ra
không ạ ạ
thì
nó sẽ có thêm những cái dụng là phẩy như
này thôi thì nó sẽ là Nhi ngủ mắc Vô Cực
tin tức à tức là sao Là sử Bây giờ tôi
cho nó thành như này thì mấy ông sẽ thấy
nó bôi được sáng hết toàn bộ nó này buổi
sáng toàn bộ nó này chính là sự đối cho
đây số nào ạ
Nó không bôi cái gì cả bởi rõ ràng là số
lại không làm cho mày ít ạ trong bảng
chữ cái thứ hai z nó nhọn
Ừ nếu hiểu Nãy giờ tôi nói gì mấy đấy
Khi Cái cái đoạn này từ a đến z lắm chị
lấy chữ trong màng cái từ A Z thôi mà nó
không ạ Và Nó đang bôi tất cả chữ nó có
bôi số chỉ số này nó không làm trong
thời gian ghét không ạ
Đúng rồi bạn kia nói khỏi cầu và trả lời
được rồi Đúng rồi nếu viết hoa thì nó sẽ
là từ a đến z thì cậu biết hoa như thế
này nhờ tí rồi sẽ chỉ cho mấy ông về
những cái nữa
ờ Ok và giả sử các bạn muốn ép nó cho là
nó bắt buộc phải là
có một giới hạn một cái gì cụ thể là sự
là giới hạn nó là 10 ký tự trở lại thì
nó sẽ là như thế này nhìn 10 và mắt mưa
chữ đầu ngồi bạn kia lại hỏi thêm một
câu cũng chuẩn nữa đó là Unicode thì nó
sẽ không được trong trường hợp này là sử
đây là Nguyễn nhà lại nhà Ông thấy à báo
bị mất mất cái chữ có dấu bởi vì cái này
nó chỉ nằm trong bảng AC nó là Index 97
tuyến inject 122 còn cách bề mà nó lấy
được Unicode thì bạn phải như hình như
mình nhớ không lầm là thêm cái Unicode
rồi đây phải
a Nhớ Ngựa Cái này nó không được Mình
mình nhớ phải áp dụng cái khác rồi
nhưng mà mình mình Đúng rồi Đúng rồi
Đúng rồi Mình quên quyền quyết riêng về
cái bắt về kệ ghi khách về chữ
chữ có dấu ấy mấy ông phải nhập đầy đủ
đầy đủ cái có dấu mà khi nào tôi sẽ gửi
cho ông cái đoạn ghét đấy nghĩa là béo
về ghi đầy đủ tất cả các trường hợp có
dấu gạo để mà thỏa mãn chưa ngoài từ A
đến Z ở đủ nữa mới qua đây tôi làm thực
ra đoạn đầy tổng góp trên mạng thôi Em
mà công nhận đấy ạ
khi nhập đầy đủ tất cả trường hợp có dấu
buồn cười cực
cái cái Min 10 mắc 10 này tức là sao tôi
thay nó là mười Nga thì mới Ông thấy là
ở đây trường hợp trường hợp chữ như này
thì nó không hề được bôi gì cả đến khi
đủ ký tự thì nó mới bắt đầu được Xá Đông
ạ
đúng ạ đó
A và ngoài ra nó còn thêm những cái gì
nữa nó còn thêm những cái viết tắt của
cái hay vì viết kiểu như này thì mấy ông
thấy rõ ràng là cái vụ một mắc Vô Cực
này nó bằng nó có phải bằng với cái kí
tự dấu cộng vừa nãy của mình vừa học ở
trên không ạ
à à
anh không không không không có cách nào
để đỡ nông dân ở không ạ à
à à
Ê mấy ông chị nó ra Cốc Cốc của ai đó về
rồi
nó con thêm cái ví dụ là sao như thế này
nó sẽ là meme không mắc Vô Cực
nghĩa là có cũng được và
à à đầu tiên không có cũng được và có
thì thoải mái đều ạ Nó sẽ bằng
à tôi ghi theo kiểu dạng như thế này thì
cạnh nhau cho mấy ông dễ hình dung đi ừ
Chúng tôi sẽ ghi trò này cho mấy ông dễ
hình dung nhé á
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
đã xóa này đi Cái này sẽ là như thế này
hoặc cái này nó sẽ là bằng không thế này
đúng ạ
Ừ
tôi gõ và chăm sóc khi tách để mày ông
mà nhìn nhìn theo nó rõ nhé ạ
Ừ nếu như đúng không ạ
ờ ờ tiếp theo là mình còn thêm cả vụ hỏi
chấm hỏi chấm nó sẽ là meme không mắc
một tất cả
như này cây cây hỏi chấm này nó sẽ có
tác dụng là nếu mà có à Nếu mà không có
cũng được và nếu có chữ phép có một đống
ngoại nó sẽ ra Kiểu kiểu dạng mà à
anh
gọi cho ông một ví dụ nó là A B C như
thế này ABC nếu công việc khớp đúng
không ạ nhưng mình nhưng mà giờ sự tôi
muốn mà AC nó cũng khớp
sự thật bà a b c nóichung ABC cũng khớp
và AC vuông góc thì mình sẽ có thêm dấu
hỏi chấm rồi đấy để để ăn Chỉ Là Vui Ve
di kỵ ký tự bên này có cũng được còn
không có không có cũng được bà Bác Hồ
chỉ có một ký tự thôi thì nó sẽ như thế
này đúng hạn thậm chí là mấy ông muốn
cho là a
ADC cũng được như thế này thì cái này nó
sẽ nằm trong cảnh ô vuông và cái này là
B hoặc B đúng ạ Họ sẽ kiểm
ảnh BHD
Ừ có gì là những cảm đấy đấy thì thì mới
ông sẽ thấy ra à thực ra là cái vụ
Ừ
nếu mà không hỏi chấm nhảy thì mới Ông
thấy à họa sĩ chỉ
thì kệ nó Nó làm i1 và mắc một nghĩa bắt
buộc phải có ký tự B D nằm ở đây đó
ngoại và nó không lấy cái C nhưng mà này
có giờ sự mình thêm hỏi chấm vào đây
chém Chị Đã Lấy ở trong này lấy trong
cái mặt vua ngày một ký tự hoặc là không
đấy Cái gì cũng được nãy bây giờ tăng
của họ chấm
ngoài ra nữa ngoài ra nữa mấy ông thấy
nãy giờ nãy giờ nó có bị một cái khó
chịu như này đây tôi cho mấy ông ví dụ
lại
ra sự là lại quay lại cái bên mail ạ
thật sự mail này đang hoa@gmail.com này
ờ
ê ê ABC
a a còng gmail.com
ạ sau đó thì một loạt ký tự xay nha
đó trước đấy là một lon ký tự sai ngay
sau đó đi ờ
Ô Long a còng chấm com
chấm xz
xong rồi một lát ý tự xanh ai tiếp chẳng
hạn thế
tôi đang cho mấy ông để mấy ông dễ hình
dung nhé
đề thi trường hợp nào đúng trường hợp
duy nhất toàn đầu nó đúng những trường
hợp sau mến miếu khi mà tetrapak mày
không phải nhập nhiều trường hợp sai và
nhiều trường hợp đúng ra nhá thì mày
không test nhé để cách để công cốt ghi
khách mời ông không ngờ nghĩ là mình cốc
luôn Chạy mình chỉ khi mỗi trường hợp
đúng lo nhé ấy trường hợp Đúng là khi mà
mình trong chuỗi người dùng nhập email
đấy nó chỉ có tồn tại Email thôi nó
không được nhập thêm bất kỳ các kí tự
đặc biệt hay vân vân thậm chí nó chỉ cần
nhập đúng cách từ đây tính sai rồi chán
thế đúng không ạ đây khi mình cần mình
cần bắt được những cái trường hợp đúng
và loại bỏ những trường hợp sai như thế
này như thế nào rõ là mấy ông bảo là nó
có chữ nó có a còng nó có tên miền đây
đây cũng tính có những gì ấy ngoài ra nó
còn thừa những cái thứ khác nữa đúng ạ
thì nó thành trường nào sai Ừ thì bây
giờ đầu tiên để bắt trường hợp đúng đã
thì mình sẽ ra từ a đến z nó ngoác ạ
ạ sau đó nó dấu cộng gì à đúng ạ là sửa
đây có thiên số đi thì mình sẽ là từ 0
đến 9 ạ không đến chí này Bắt được rồi
này a còng này đúng không ạ sống vậy anh
nhỉ Rét này
rồi cậu này sau đó thì Dấu chấm này cho
lại từ A Z vô lại cậu khô có vẻ chuẩn
rồi có vẻ thôi các bạn thấy là đằng sau
này nó lại đang có một loạt ký tự mình
muốn loại những cái những cái này nó sẽ
bỏ lỗi những cái thằng sau này thì mình
làm nha Bây giờ mới ông sẽ biết thêm
được phải khái niệm nữa đó là dấu ngoặc
à dấu mũ này để bắt đầu
Trỗi
nghĩa là mấy ông để ý thấy là cái Long
này cái trường hợp 3 và 4 này nó bị sai
điểm là bắt đầu chỗ ấy Nó không phải là
là những thứ mà mình cần đúng ạ thì mình
sẽ có thêm vào đây thì sẽ là giàu như
thế này đó thì mấy ông sẽ thấy là bắt
đầu chuỗi mỗi dòng của tôi là một chỗ
nhá ngày hôm nay Hình dung là tôi đang
kiểm tra từng dòng Từng dòng này tách
điện nhau dòng này có thể đúng không có
nghĩa dòng dưới nó nó đúng nó không ạ Nó
độc lập nhau đúng không ạ Đấy thì cái
dùng cái này để bắt đầu chuỗi cái chỗ
này thì nó vẫn đang đúng này Chỗ này vẫn
đúng rồi nó bắt đầu vào nha cọ bắt đầu
Thịnh bằng Email núm còn chuỗi này thì
nó sai rồi bởi vì a email đó nằm ở giữa
đúng ạ email này nằm ở cuối nó sai không
ạ Nhưng mà thế này vẫn chưa đủ đúng
không ạ Nếu không thấy à Cái Email của
mình nó bắt đầu thì cứ về đúng rồi nhưng
đằng sau nó ký tự sau đó ông ạ Bây giờ
mình biết thêm về nữa đó là độ La thì đó
là kết thúc Trỗi I ý nghĩa bắt buộc mà
phải có cuối nữa đúng ạ Mình sẽ thêm cái
này ở cuối
đó thì mới Ông thấy à trong trường hợp
này thì chỉ có mỗi cái này nó hợp lại
thôi còn những cái này thì nó sẽ bị loại
bỏ chúng vọng Nếu mấy ông kết hợp cả cái
dấu này và cả dấu này nữa thì là ổn nhất
đó là ăn chia tôi thường hay nói cái câu
nó từ đầu đến cuối nó sẽ chỉ khớp với
những cái mà mình nhập theo gạch thôi
thì ở chuẩn không ạ những cái mà nhập
ngoài gạch thì nó sẽ bị lỗi xóa đoạn này
đi nó nhận không ạ thêm một dấu cắt thôi
cái nó lỗi đúng không ạ Đấy thì đây đây
là đầy đủ có tương đối đầy đủ của cái cơ
bản của khách cũng đúng 10 dòng không ạ
khá ổn xã hội
Ê mấy ông thấy nãy giờ cũng không đến
nỗi đau não làm đúng ạ Không nói đầu lọ
nào lắm Ừ Tôi sẽ chỉ cho ông thêm mấy
cái tắt hơn ờ ờ
mì cái tắt hơn một tí giống như là nãy
của ông nói về cái vụ lại tê thì nó sẽ
là thay cho một đoạn Tát hay cấp thử mấy
ông cha biết qua rồi Nếu mà còn w ngay
cơ
w như thế này thì nó sẽ là
nó là nó là chủ ấy vừa từ a đến z vừa là
từ a đến z như thế này và vừa từ 0 đến 9
như thế này nó khá phù hợp cho việc làm
mấy ông muốn bắt thay vì mấy ông nhập
giữa dài như thế này nếu không đổi nó
thành như thế này thôi là được Nếu không
sẽ truyện ngắn hơn
hai a thì vừa nãy mình có nói là cái
doman này cũng thể có số giáo sư tử mà
đúng ạ thì người ông đổi hết nó thành
như này là xong à
Em có biết Hoa được nhỉ Mình nhớ là có
đúng không có Và trong hai cách để có
cái nó cũng tiện hơn một tí nó là nếu mà
ông viết nó thành viết hoa hay tưởng như
thế này thì không phải lắm chỉ nó chỉ
lấy từ a đến z như thế này đó ạ Nó không
phải lấy từ a đến z như thế này đâu
và thứ ba là mấy ông cũng đừng nghĩ
trường hợp và có thể biết theo cậu a nhỏ
đến z lớn cái này nó sẽ dậy từ A Z cả
nhỏ và lớn nhé Không tôi từng thử cái
này không được đều ngoại anh sẽ biết
cách riêng cái việc tiết hoa như này nó
là ngược lại với tất cả Đồng Nai ngược
lại tất cả Đồng Nai tất cả xa nó sẽ ghi
theo cậu dạng là anh như thế này tớ là
Ngược lại nếu mà cái ngọt vua ngừa kết
hợp với cái dấu dấu mũ như này thì nó
hiểu là ngược lại tất cả những thứ trong
mặc vua nhé Đấy và ngược lại tất cả đống
này tức là sao làm mọi thứ tự khác không
nằm trong cái phạm vi hai thôi Đúng mặt
mọi thứ tự giống như là kiểu Ả cong số
10 như này không ạ chỉ nó cái gì đó nữa
rất nhiều dấu cách mà ông Tính
anh
không ạ Đấy Và nếu mà Mấy ông chỉ muốn à
số từ 0 đến 9 thôi thì nó sẽ là
như thế này không đến 99 để ngoạn và
đương nhiên ngược lại với nó như này thì
nó sẽ là
mọi thứ mọi thứ không nằm trong phạm vi
từ 0 đến 9 thì nó sẽ lấy
tôi cái dấu
không đến chính nó sẽ lấy ba giống như
cái cuối nữa như vừa nãy Các bạn nhớ cái
dấu chấm nó thay thế cho nó bằng mọi thứ
tự chống lại mọi thứ tự ở đây cả số cả
chữ cá sấu cách nói cho mọi thứ không ạ
ạ
ở đó tương đối tượng Đối cũng nhớ phết
ông ạ
Ừ thôi sẽ chia sẻ cho mấy ông hai cái
đường link này để nó học thêm thì ghét
tôi có lưu có có để sẵn ở trên này luôn
rồi này tôi thì tôi tôi tí thôi sẽ bình
luận cả cái đoạn này kết hợp với hai cái
này để người Ông đọc qua hai cái này nó
còn nói thêm thêm một vài cái ví dụ nữa
ờ ờ
có thêm một vài cái ví dụ nữa Rất là hay
đây có một đoạn tương đối đầy đủ Mày
không cần nhớ này ạ
ạ Và bây giờ để tránh dài làm hơn bây
giờ áp dụng bài tập lý thuyết nãy giờ
nhiều quá thế là sự áp dụng bài tập bây
giờ tôi sẽ dậy người ông từ cái cơ bản
nhất mà tôi thường dậy sinh viên Đó là
thì mình sẽ dùng gạch để mà kiểm tra số
điện
Ờ thì đầu tiên ở đây số điện thoại thì
nó thường hay
thường Bây giờ giả sử số điện thoại giờ
làm Mấy mô số rằng ạ người nên muốn sống
nhé
số 10 Nguyễn Tôi cũng chả nhớ nữa cứ cho
là sự có hỗ trợ luôn cảm nhận 10 số và
11 số đi là xử thế không ạ thì à
anh cái số điện thoại thì mình sẽ yêu
cầu nó chị chỉ Nhật
xe chính chủ nhật mà nó là số không bằng
đầu hay gì gì đó xong rồi đằng sau bằng
ban đầu nó bắt buộc phải số Không em ạ
sôi đằng sau nó không được không được là
số 0 Để hạn Vân Vân Vân thì sao ta sử
mình hỗ trợ cho toàn nhập 11 số luôn đi
cho nó khó
đầu tiên tôi nhập một số hợp lệ đã này
là sự đây một số lệnh số này thôi Chẳng
biết nó ba số nữa Hình như là 10 số này
đấy
ở đây là 10 số thì phải ạ
em bỏ qua vụ 84 đi nhé mà Mấy ông Muốn
làm cộng tám tư thì đấy sẽ ra câu sau
cho bé Ông tôi đang dạy cơ bản
Ừ không sao Cái gì về sau thuốc chữa hết
cho béo mấy không phải lo mà ông cứ thắc
mắc gì tôi sẽ giải đáp cho đây đây rồi
Cứ giả sử đây một số đúng không ạ nhưng
một số sai nó sẽ như thế nào không không
không như ai cũng có một số sai đúng ạ
tớ bỏ qua vụ nhập chữ nhá Tí mình chắc
chắn mình không cho nhập chữ rồi
Không nhưng lại có một số Sai rồi Không
ạ Mấy ông cứ bát hết các trường hợp sai
đi trở lại
ờ ờ con trường hợp chị nha
a123 nghe đây là mình Đây là những
chuyện đó sau trừ nhập đúng nó sẽ nghe
tạm thời Tôi chưa nghĩ được thì em
trường hợp sai được
cho sự thêm hạn như này không không nhỉ
À đây cũng trường có sai rồi chồng ạ
thì à còn trường hợp sai nữa
thôi chỉ cần đổi cái này thành không
nghe thì ông thấy nó đủ độ dài nhưng mà
tự nhiên số là người sau số còn lại số 0
thì nó càng sai không ạ đó
Ừ thì mấy ông cầm đầu tiên là như tôi
thường à
anh như tôi vừa ấy nói nó là nên có số
không được đâu đây số không bằng đầu Ok
không ạ sau đó thì là một loạt số nhưng
không có số 0 đằng động đối ngoại thì
mình sẽ là một đến chí chuẩn chọn đó
Ừ Để cho để cho mấy ông biết được là
mình là đúng hay sai mình sẽ cho ngay
như thế này Trước đó thì mình sẽ thấy nó
bắt
0101 ok rồi ông ạ đó nó sẽ bỏ qua thằng
này luôn này nhưng mà sau đó lại sổ tiếp
ngay không ạ mì ông trong số đằng sau
này mình hoàn toàn nó có thể để số 02
không ạ chúng sau này có thể để số 0 2 0
ra sư có gọi cho phép bằng sau nó có thể
anh có thể để số không đi
anh hả
200 gọi liên tỉnh
em
bỏ qua đi bộ qua vụ là tôi tôi đã bắt
trường hợp mà không có số 0 đằng sau đã
còn nếu mấy ông Hỗ trợ nó thì càng ngon
thôi
ở
đằng sau này có thể có số không chẳnghạn
Thế thì mình sẽ là từ 0 đến 9 tiếp thôi
ông ạ
đó và đoạn này mình muốn cho lại từ đây
trở đi thì mình nhập số gì cũng được vẫn
được tính không ạ khi
ở đây thì nó sẽ là
số
một này
2345678
nghĩa làm chị là mình sẽ nhập đầy đủ 8
số đằng sau
đó nó sẽ như thế này
và đương nhiên vừa nãy mình bảo là có
thể hỗ trợ được cho cả 10 tháng 11 số
thì mình sẽ làm chị lại nếu mà như thế
này thì thành sai rồi ạ thì mình sẽ 8
phẩy trí đó và như thế này nó sẽ hỗ trợ
anh nhìn này và đương nhiên là bây giờ
nếu là thêm sống xong ngay thì đang lại
phải không thỏa mãn mà không ạ sự mình
thêm số lần sau này lẽ không này không
thỏa mãn thì mình sẽ có đô la đó
ở đây đây là sẽ Black cơ bản các bạn
thôi về số điện thoại Thế ông vừa bảo là
thêm cộng tám tư cái gì đấy Nó nhọn thì
đổi không Này cộng 84 được gì không ạ
thì mình sẽ nếu mà trong trường hợp và
mấy ông muốn đổi cái một chuỗi ký tự với
một chuỗi ký tự kiểu như thế thì nó sẽ
là thì cho nó vào mặt tròn như này rồi
kết hợp với cái dấu thăm á dấu à Chỗ Cho
biết bên cạnh gạch thẳng như thế này về
hiểu là một về bên trái hay bên phải là
sự đây A và DZ giống như vậy tôi là
à à
Ừ nếu mà nếu mà ghi kiểu nhảy thời gian
mình có thể hiểu được là một loại A2 là
Z ngay luôn Nhưng nếu giờ sự mình đi một
đoạn nó nó dài hơn như thế này
như này chẳng hạn à à lái xe đi khi mấy
ông lại khó ghi theo kiểu vuông ngay
đúng không ạ thì cách để mình hiểu cái
này thì nó sẽ là à AB hoặc DC đó ông ạ
đúng ạ thì thì đầy đầy cái gì đúng
cái cách này có thể ghi ngắn nhưng riêng
cách này thì không nên nhắn được mình sẽ
về đi mình sẽ hiểu Nó là những này thôi
đấy
thì nó sẽ ở đây cũng thế là sử thay dù
số không thành cái cộng 84 thì nó sẽ là
đôi cái này thành hoặc như thế này cộng
84 đúng không ạ
đó và ở đây nhiều ở đây nó đang cảnh báo
lỗi bởi vì cậu ở đây nó hiểu kí tự đặc
biệt thì mình thêm xấu như này đó thì
mới Ông thấy À cái màu ở đây Nếu được
nghỉ màu đấy nhá màu đây nó ở đây mấy
ông sẽ để nếu cho mặt tròn ngay đôi khi
nó sẽ tạo thêm cái gọi rốt nữa nó sẽ tạo
màu nó chứ nó không nghĩ ám chỉ là nó
tạo thành cái thằng cái thằng trong mặt
tròn nó sẽ biến thành một cái giúp g một
cái nhóm riêng chứ nó không phải là lỗi
và nó cũng không ảnh hưởng gì cả vì em
chuyển mát của mình vẫn mát để cho nó
vẫn khớp có nếu mà giờ xử ông không muốn
có cái giúp này được tạo ra
Anh không muốn cái lúc này đã tạo ra
chẳng qua cái này cốt là để mà muốn phân
biệt kế hàng cộng 84 ta sử dụng trường
hợp này tôi đổi không Đảng cộng 84 này
vẫn chạy này không ạ ra xử ông không
muốn có cái có cái này thì chị ra tôi
tôi bị cầu toàn nên tôi nhìn thấy cái
thì thị ra nghe tôi không trục khi nếu
có thể thêm cái ký tự nó là hỏi chấm 2
chấm nhớ anh thì nó sẽ hiểu là cánh cái
mặc kệ ngọt trò này nó không tạo thêm
một cái gốc là nữa
điều hòa thế thôi
thế là tôi nói quà cho những cái ông mà
cậu Toàn như tôi nhìn nó đỡ ngứa mắt nở
ra nó không anh hưởng gì cái lôgic và nó
không bị lỗi cốt bởi vì bản chất là nó
đã khớp cái mắt rồi ông ạ ạ
Ừ ok đấy mẹ ông thắc mắc về cụm từ bây
giờ đáp cho ông luôn đấy lại thế Hết câu
xa cho mày không người ở
a tiếp theo thì vẫn có thời gian không ạ
Mình sẽ chữa dần những cái cái bài khó
hơn Ừ cái này vừa rồi mấy mấy ông hiểu
cái này chưa ạ Mày không hiểu cái tôi
vừa làm về cái số điện thoại bọn
tôi tạm chưa Gửi cho mấy ông cái cốt này
đâu để cuối khóa học về cách này ra để
buổi sau nữa đi thì tôi sẽ gửi cho cả
whey với cả họ tên của tôi tôi làm cái
quả mà họ tên có dấu ở như thế nào ạ
anh béo hiểu đúng không Ok mày không còn
Tự nhận mày không hiểu nhé Để tớ sẽ nhảy
sang cái khó hơn này vợ tôi sẽ thử làm
rách với tuổi đi tuổi tuổi thì ta xử
được phép nhập Tôi thường ngoài chẳng ở
trong cái ở trên nhật tuổi cả nếu mà giả
sử được phép nhập tuổi thì mấy ông nhập
tuổi
về giá sữa tuổi hiện tại bao nhiêu tuổi
người đang sống ngoài tuổi đã mất rồi
thì tuổi người đang sống nhưng giờ sự
làm mấy ông chỉ được phép nhập tôi sẽ
ghi điều kiện của đề bài là nha
nhập tuổi
hiện tại của bạn
không chơi mày ông ngoài ba mang gọi
rồng hà ra dưới nhé đấy thì tuổi của mấy
ông thì đương nhiên là không có phải
phải phải gì Chán thế mày ông bắt buộc
phải nhập số nguyên em ạ Không ạ thì nếu
tuổi nó sẽ không có số 0 là đầu đúng
không ạ thì con sẽ nhập nó có những cái
trường hợp có thể xảy ra ở đây thử
nghiệm nhập số tuổi như thế này không ạ
12 tuổi 18 tuổi đúng ạ sau nhập số hai
thằng đầu nó vẫn được đó ngoại sự hay
mốt 25 gì đó nhập 100 cũng được dọn ra
sử cho tôi chị cho ông Bởi vì người dài
nhất Bây giờ hình như nó chưa lên nên
nổi hơn 200 tuổi nhưng tôi chỉ cho ông
nhập một có số 100 đang đầu là à với với
3 số thì sẽ chỉ được nói chung nhà tuổi
của ông sẽ phải bé hơn 200 ạ đến 200
tượng bé ông Cùng lắm nhập được 199 thôi
không thấy phép nhập 200 đối ngoại ô
Ừ thì mấy ông sẽ làm như thế nào
á nhon
A và đưa nghe có thể nhập cả số tuổi
kiểu 80 được nhập số 0 nhé Không mẹ nói
tôi không Tôi luôn nhé là sự 89 Cái gì
đó nghĩa là như thế này không Tôi bảo
rồi không có nhập số 0 lần đầu ngay
không cho nhập đều ạ
Cho sẽ copy giai đoạn này
bạn ra đây Nhập tôi không ạ thì cái giải
quyết bài toán ở đây thì khi mà Làm lập
trình các bạn phải chia các trường hợp
ra các bạn không thể ghi ngay một phát
freegate ăn ngay chắc lại xuống hợp cách
để chia trường hợp của tôi xuống ấy là
đó là tắt cái này ra thành nhiều trường
hợp Ê mấy ông Để ý kỹ ở đây cho da bạn
chất ở đây có 3 trường hợp thôi ba
trường hợp với Đây là gì trường hợp 1 là
nó có một ký tự trường hợp hai nó có hai
thứ tự là ba là 3 ký tự đấy Đấy là cách
của tôi chưa chụp tôi đã xử lý nó như
sau tôi sẽ tách cả ngày ra làm 3 tát tôi
sẽ tạo đã ký kết 38 ngày mà tôi giveback
từng cái tát một rồi Tôi ghét mà nó vào
với nhau đến mấy ông hiểu nó hiểu đấy
giờ tôi muốn nói em ạ lại tôi sẽ tạo đầy
38 o
Ừ thế này ổn nhất này Đấy và trường hợp
một số trước đi một số thì mình chỉ là
đơn giản đó là trong phạm vi từ 1 đến
chí ra sóng của dễ gãy
ở đại và mình thêm thế này để chắc chắn
nó là một số
Anh ăn rồi mình số 0 Nhưng lại không
không hợp lệ đúng ạ số 5 nhãn hợp đấy
ông ạ MT sao được
anh không trường nào mẹ anh đi được cái
này bắt buộc phải nhập một ký tự mà
không ạ Đó ok không ạ xong trường có mối
rồi dễ như trò đùa trường hợp thứ hai là
thị trường hợp thứ 2 thì nó 2 số đúng
không ạ hai số thì mình cần là
Ừ ông kia chơi chưa
anh không cốt của ông kia nhìn thấy chưa
tối ưu rồi để tôi làm cho mình xem à ở
trường hợp thứ hai là gì nó hai số và số
đầu của nó là từ 1 đến 9 từ 1 đến 9 bởi
vì như tôi đã nói tôi không cho phép
nhập số 0 như này thì lúc đầu nó sẽ từ 1
đến 9
và sau đó là tử không trí
buổi đơn giản
Có lẽ thế này mà cũng đố đúng ạ
Tại vì này ok chưa ạ
Cái 080 thỏa mãn nó không không chắc
chắn không thỏa mãn nổi không ạ Người Ấy
thỏa mãn ok rồi thế đồ vào nó ạ
999 đó đưa đó không ạ Bây giờ trường hợp
thứ ba nó là gì trường hợp thứ ba nó là
bắt Nếu mà cho nhập 200 nữa ạ hãy hãy
tưởng chỉ 300 em ạ Chị 350
355 hay gì đó nó vẫn không thỏa mãn
không ạ thế làm chỉ là số 1 lúc đầu có
này số 1 bắt đầu nó số một này cho chắc
cụ này đó sau đó là gì không đến 9 thôi
không mình chín ở đây không Mình chín
đây hai phát một làm mấy ông yêu cậu làm
lại như này theo kiểu nếu bị rảnh hay là
mấy ông có thể viết tắt viết theo kiểu
ngay cho nó bắt buộc là phải hai ký tự Ừ
đúng
Ừ để ra sự thu nhập số 10 Nga trong mấy
ông biết là nó có thể xay nha ông ạ
và mấy ông có thể làm ngắn hơn sống
nhưng tôi bảo thì nó sẽ là bên này Đây
là sai không chỉ mà các bạn Nếu bạn đó
thì kiểu này nó sẽ ngắn hơn tí không ạ
Nói nhiên cái này bắt buộc nó phải có
cuối đi phòng nó 1000 cái gì đó nó không
bị lỗi
kết hợp cả ba cái này với nhau thì sẽ là
như thế nào
Ừ tôi sẽ đắp I kết một cái Tab nữa rồi
tôi nhét cả ba cái bạn cho mình không xe
em copy này à
à à
ảnh copy nó sẽ dùng dầu hoặc này copy
này
à Xong rồi lại
hoặc copy ở anh có ghé xong OK Ngon thế
Xong rồi nhưng cái này chưa đủ tối ưu
cái này chưa đủ Tôi yêu
Ờ chưa tối ưu chỗ nào mấy ông thấy có
nhiều cá nó bị lặp lại và cách để tối ưu
của tôi đó là như thế này tôi sẽ rút gọn
đi hai cái này lặp lại đúng không ạ Nó
khác nhau điểm gì khác nhau điểm là cái
này đằng sau đúng nghĩa tức là hai này
thì chụp lại theo kiểu Cái này có hoặc
không có cũng được không ạ là sẽ gộp lại
hai cái này cho mấy ông xe à
Anh ở Xóa cái trường hợp một này đi Này
tốc độ này có không có cũng được đấy đó
đấy số 8 ông ạ
ờ ờ
Ê mấy ông vào vào tầm giờ này thì tự
nhiên mày cũng khó hiểu đúng rồi cuối
giờ mà đi tua lại video đi tiếp theo
ờ ờ
thế ông cũng thành chụp lại này để tôi
biết lại cái này cho mấy ông nhìn nó
tiện nhé không đến chí này vào đây cũng
à
không đến chí này ạ
à À không không nên chí này thì mày
không thấy à
Ừ cái này nó giống nhau ở mỗi điểm hai
cái này không đến 9 là thường là tôi
tách thằng này ra đấy tôi không ngô Còn
lâu cho đỡ nhìn nó mắt mấy ông muốn gộp
lại Thực ra nó cũng phức tạp ra như tôi
tôi không có hai thằng ngày với nhau
thế nhưng tôi có thể nộp cái dấu ký tự
này với nhau được
cái dấu ký tự này nó sẽ là tôi sẽ gộp
vào nghe thì xóa đi này Ừ thôi đổ cái
này thành tròn như thế này
chú
chó nếu không sẽ thấy nó như thế này à
À cái Ngó trò này nó sẽ méo nhớ bạn nó
trò này nó sẽ để hiểu các cụ này nó sẽ
được thừa hưởng cái dấu dấu đôla với dấu
mũ như này đến hiểu từ đầu đến cuối
nhưng mấy ông thấy khó chịu việc làm
hoặc tròn nó tạo thêm cái súp nữa thì
méo Có thể thêm hỏi chấm 2 chấm nó sẽ
sau đúng ạ thì mày Ông thấy đầy đủ Nó là
kiểu rút gọn nó có thể đến như thế này
đây về kiểm tra về tuổi theo phạm vi là
tuổi từ ở tuổi của tôi nó sẽ là từ 1 cho
đến 1999 Đông ạ vào số nguyên ok
Ê mấy ông đến đoạn Hiếu
anh tặng đâu Đông não chưa
3 bài tập của tôi sẽ yêu cầu làm lại mấy
cái này đấy à
Em
không hiểu
thì uống miếng nước bạn ạ
Ừ cái này kiến thức mới mấy ông mà hiểu
được cái mấy ông thành siêu nhân quá à à
à Nếu như thầy tôi từ ngày bảo đó là
thôi mấy ông lại điều khiển thế nào được
về xem lại đi Cái thứ thử
địa chỉ ở cá nó lại dễ địa chỉ nó bản
chất nó là số kết hợp với chuỗi chuỗi
chữ lòng giao thôi
thôi sẽ dạy cho ông ấy không ngại tiếp
để nếu mình dùng rõ rồi mấy cái này đó
là
Ừ
ông kia còn thích viết tắt nữa Thôi đừng
ham đi tắm nữa thôi
Dù thế nào vẫn có thể đi tắt được như
ông kia bảo
à à
đề nghị ông kia làm như có thể sẽ sai
bởi vì cái này 1 đến 9 giờ nếu mà ông
trùng đến nhà ở dưới đê Nó không đúng
đâu ạ ờ ờ
ạ Bây giờ tôi sẽ chữa cho mày ông tiếp
đó là về số
em vẫn làm vé số đi nhà số lần này số đi
số điểm của tôi nó như thế này tôi sẽ có
đề bài nhá
điểm
từ phạm vi từ ngủ với mưa à từ 0 đến 10
chứ và
số thợ có thể là số thập phân
và sau dấu phẩy
có tối đa 2 số
có trường hợp thì những trường hợp gì
xảy ra ở đây nhất là số không thích sẵn
rồi đúng không ạ Có chưa một số 10 sẽ
sẵn rồi ngoại à từ
0,5 cũng đúng 0,25 cũng đúng không ạ
5,25 phải 5,75 đúng không ạ
55 5,0 nữa hàng sai đúng tôi sẽ cho
trường hợp này sai nhé rồi cho trường
rồi mẹ sai
những trường nào sai đi
ờ ờ
À sau dấu phẩy
Ở đây có thể dấu phẩy hình số chấm được
là sự tôi cho à
cách nhau bởi phẩy hoặc chấm chả thế
tôi quen Dạo này quen dùng chấm ở giữa
rồi quen làm việc bên nước ngoài nó rung
chấm
sai thì nó sẽ là 3,3 dùng như bạn cái
bảo đi đúng ạ
3,03 thì đúng không ạ đây Thôi cho
trường hợp này đúng anh trên này thường
ấy tôi cách như thế này cho các bạn biết
trường hợp sai có ai tôi gõ hẳn bên này
đi Đấy Chụp sai nữa là gì nó là 10
10,5 ạ
em bỏ qua việc âm nhé Mình không cho
nhập âm nó nó sẽ không sinh ra được
đúng rồi
3,30 nữa đó đây những trường hợp sai
đúng không ạ
à Không để bày lần này chuẩn đối không
xa Tôi Thuộc cái đề bài rồi tôi dậy sinh
viên
Ừ Ok mấy ông dụng nói chung mấy ông hình
dung được cái vụ này chị ạ
300 bê không cần máy không phải nhập ký
tự đặc biệt có dấu cách 2 ký tự hay là
sổ chữ vào trong này đâu của vịt mình
chỉ nhập số là không không có thể nhập
ra được kí tự đặc biệt đâu
ạ bây bây giờ để tôi hỏi mấy ông trước
khi tôi bắt tay vào làm đấy Nó nhìn qua
tất cả lúc này không ạ Nếu không thử nói
cho tôi biết mấy ông sẽ chia nó thành
mấy trường hợp
anh ạ
những mẹo sẽ chia nó thành mấy trường
hợp để mấy ông lạc với ông càng chia
chuẩn thì mấy ông càng làm Chuẩn từng
trường hợp xuống ghét hết vào với nhau
và sự rất ổn một tí tao còn rút gọn ra
mấy ông ấy Ông nhìn cái đoạn rút gọn lại
hoa mắt nha ạ
ở Nhà Bè ở trước hết thì mày nói là tôi
đi ạ mấy ông sẽ chia cái trường hợp này
thành mấy trường nhà ở
có hai trường hợp nếu nói cụ thể hơn để
nhận tốt Nó là nếu không sẽ chơi trường
hợp ah1 là gì trường hợp hay là gì nóng
hôm nay giống như bạn kia nói trường hợp
số nguyên này một số thập phân này hai
số thập phân này Ok cũng được
xe bốn chỗ ở 74 trường hợp nó gì
em nói cụ thể hơn tí em ạ ạ
13 trường hợp
i10 có phải và tròn thì nó giữa ba
trường hợp đúng không
du lịch thi AFF
thứ năm tuần này tuần sau ngọn hai
trường hợp số nguyên và số thập phân rồi
thì đơn giản quá bơ để tôi trời ông nhé
bốn trường hợp có cái này đúng không
biết phải ông nghĩ dùm tôi không muốn
trường hợp nó sẽ là à số 10 là một
trường hợp số một số nguyên là một
trường hợp à
số có một số thập phân là một trường hợp
và số có hai thập phân là hạn và một
trường hợp nữa tổng cộng của 4 trường
hợp lại sẽ tạo ra quy kết thành 4 Tab A
ở
trường hợp số 10 thì đơn giản đội nón số
10 không ạ Hết xăng rồi tí gì hết ạ tiếp
trường hợp tiếp theo đó là một số nguyên
nó thực ra cũng dễ thôi sao đơn giản dễ
chơi dễ trúng kia ông ạ
ở trường hợp nữa đương nhiên thì tôi bảo
rồi tự nhiên phải kết hợp cả nhưng này
như thế này nữa đúng không Nhưng mà thôi
tí thì tính sau thì tính sao không ạ
trường hợp này thì may ra nhìn Nếu đỡ
rối thì mới ông thể làm ngay trước để
cho chắc cú đi
thì số 5 Này ổn không ạ Okay
tiếp tục chưa mà khó hơn là
chỉ có một số
một số mọn tối xóa tôi xóa mấy trường ở
máy đi nha
À thôi Để đấy cũng được không sao không
sao ạ
ờ ờ một số thập phân thì bằng trước nó
số nguyên từ 0 đến 9 đoạn loại bỏ số 10
rồi em à đúng ngoại thì Chứ không đến 9
thôi sau đó sẽ là dấu chấm em ạ Tí mấy
ông hiện đổi dấu phẩy sao tính sau
sau đó thì một số một số đơn giản thôi
một số thì mình tự từ 1 đến 9 bởi vì như
tôi đang làm thì nó sẽ là không có
trường hợp
bạn 5.0 ngay đó Bọn tôi không muốn cho
trường hợp 5.0 này không ạ cái bắt đầu
đầu hãy bắt đầu lần cuối này để bắt buộc
toàn bộ phải đúng đi đó thì nó không
phải nắm đúng nó ngọt dụ là
9,9 nó cũng đúng không ạ Và trường hợp
tiếp theo nữa cuối cùng
nó là trường hợp à
à à
em
nộp nó là trường hợp
ở một số số này có thể số không đúng
không ạ sau đó là số từ 1 đến 9 ngoại
thì nó sẽ là
không này Không chín và sau đó là 1 đến
đó thế là được không ạ
khi bé là trường hợp hai số thập phân
loại
em mình kết hợp đi bây giờ mình sẽ kết
hợp lại tất cả đấu này với nhau
ở đại tôi sẽ copy
ở bên này
copy này
hoặc thêm phát nữa này copy này lại hoặc
thêm phần nữa này đúng hết toàn bộ cái
trên cái dưới này nó đang say vì thôi
Không cho cái này
đó đúng rồi đúng không ạ Thế sau thế này
thì ra mấy ông làm này thì mấy ông có vẻ
hạnh phúc Đi về đâu rồi thế điểm nó
tương đối rồi con mếu muốn 10 mẫu muốn
kiểu rút gọn lại tôi nhìn ngứa mắt không
ạ ru họ những cái gì đầu tiên vừa nãy
tôi bảo có thể rút gọn cho cậu lại rút
gọn một cái chị cái cái ký tự này trước
đã gì không ạ Chị sẽ gốc rút gọn mặt này
và thôi đỡ Khó chịu gì tôi sẽ cho cái họ
xem hai chấm trước được khó chịu ok có
rút gọn được gì nữa không Mình có thể
rút gọn được mấy cũng khi bị kỹ là đầu
tiên là
số bằng đầu nó đứng trước đang đầu theo
ngày đầu lâu nó ngày và đang Thằng này
nó luôn 090 ạ thì lắm chị ạ Mấy thằng
này thứ là
Ê thằng thằng Súng một số Nghiên này nó
có thể là đằng sau nó có kí tự đặc biệt
này hoặc không à Có cảm cái chỗ ấy đằng
sau hoặc không có được Nếu nghe kỹ rồi
nó nhé 8 chỉ là số nguyên
số 5 Này có thể là có một chuỗi phẩy
phẩy phẩy đằng sau và kèm với đó là một
số gì đó hoặc không có cũng được thì rõ
ràng cả cái cụ mày đó là hỏi chấm đúng
không ạ nghĩa có không có cũng được thì
tớ là sao thì xóa cái này để ý
a cho các cụ mày
ảnh có không có được đó mếu thấy nó sẽ
nha nếu thêm hỏi chấm 2 chấm nữa thì nó
sẽ loại bỏ đi
ok không ạ
Và tiếp theo đó nữa vậy ông thấy là hai
thằng này nó khác gì nhau ạ Nó có còn
thưởng cái hàng này ở giữa Thằng này
không đấy Cái tội xóa luôn cả hai đi
Ê bà đây nó cho thằng này chen ở giữa
này không đến 9 giờ không ạ hỏi chấm này
thế là xong ở đâu muốn rút gọn thân nữa
tốn chữa tôi nghĩa thì ngưỡng ngày thôi
Ừ
ông vừa nãy ông làm bài trước ông thấy
kết quả của ông giống thôi không không
đúng không Thì ông sửa đi
ừ Địt nếu cần Nếu mà chưa học gì mới học
thì kế hoạch này không hiểu gì không Nếu
mà tôi mà không làm từng bước từng bước
nhỏ như thế Tôi gộp luôn nghe từ lúc đầu
kiểu viết tắt nghe mấy đứa chẳng hiểu gì
đúng không mày Ông nhìn cái đoạn này Thế
nên sửa rách trong mấy ông công nhận là
giữ khó trong nước phức tạp của bọn mình
không thích Đấy lý do tôi bảo mấy cũng
phải ghi hết các trường hợp sai ra nữa
và làm từ từ thôi làm từ từ thôi xong
rồi Chỗ rút gọn rút gọn dần thì nó như
thế này thế này cái số 10 này thì bỏ qua
đúng ạ mì ông tôi tôi sẽ cho mày ông xem
lại cái vụ này thôi
Ừ
cái này nó là gì Cái này trước nó là một
số gì đó đúng ạ
Nó số gì đó số 0 mà số 5 là nó ngọn mời
cả cái cụm lần sau nó là có không có
được không ạ là sự 5,5 này thì được đúng
ạ Đấy
ôi cái đoạn này thậm chí ở hệ rút gọn
được thêm này rồi chấm này có thể thay
bằng giống như tôi nói là nó thể 5 phẩy
5,5 được thì bé ông ấy đổi nó thay nhà
để nó trong mọc vuông nhé
Vậy thế này
khi để
Ừ để nó để nó trong ngoặc vuông nhà thì
nó hình như nó biến thành Chị ở ký tự
Bình thường thôi nên là không lo gì lắm
Ừ
đúng rồi để nó trong mọc vuông này nó
hiểu thì tự bình thường này ra mấy cũng
để thi kiểu nhạc đấy à
ở đằng sau nó có không có cũng được này
và sau đó thì cái cái này có không có
cũng được thành ra là sẽ không có trường
hợp 5 phẩy
A
5,50 ở đằng sau nhé Đúng không ạ
ừ ừ
em có đó cách mở gak và
cậu rút gọn nó thì nó như thế nào
anh cũng đau não được ạ tôi chữa chữa
cho ông béo về cái họ tên đâu
cách chữa nốt lại họ tên gồm mình nghỉ
nha Hay là thôi đau não đủ
khi họ tên ở lại thì tôi có đề nói như
thế này họ tên này bỏ qua có dấu nhé bỏ
qua có dấu họ tên thì thì họ tên chuẩn
là như thế nào là chữ đầu tiên của tên
nó phải viết hoa không ạ Tôi bỏ qua có
tên có kí tự đặc biệt nhé
thì dù là sự Đào Nguyễn Nhã Long nha Bỏ
qua có dấu không ạ
có khi mấy ông bị kỹ tên ở đây nó sẽ là
gì nó là
ô chữ đầu tiên viết hoa này
ạ sau đó cắt gái sau đó chữ đầu tiên
tiếp theo nó lại viết hoa này đúng ạ sợ
cách một cái nữa đúng ạ Thôi sẽ gõ cho
mấy ông ạ
em thật sự tên đúng nó như thế này
tên sai nó có thể ra như này nó sẽ là
à Nguyễn nhà
miễn Nam ngay không ạ
Giả sử là
Anh tên Sai nó cũng chỉ đơn giản như anh
nó là Nguyễn Long tự nhiên này thừa cách
ở cuối nhớ lại nó sai Tôi chỉ muốn là
cách trị nằm trong khoảng vi tên như này
thôi đó
à à
à À đúng rồi tên cũng có thể hái chữ bốn
chữ đúng không ạ sử Nguyễn ai chẳng hạn
vẫn đúng
Anh tên truyện một chữ này thôi Miễn anh
vẫn đúng à
xe
tải kiểu Nga vẫn đúng chứ cách cách để
mà mịn
3 cách để mình bắt những cái trường hợp
như thế này như thế nào chữ đầu tiên với
hoa đúng
ở đoạn này thì tôi không chia trường hợp
thì cả tôi sẽ chỉ làm gặp gặp lại thôi
Không không có chữ ngờ thì gặp nhưng mà
tôi sẽ là mấy cậu đơn giản trước viết
tắt a xuống Mỹ rút làm tắt đi thì béo sẽ
thấy như thế nào ạ
Lê Nguyễn Long hình sai chắc kiểu gì đấy
trách mừng cơm rồi em
bởi vì không thì ông sẽ check theo từ
điển để ông kiểm tra xem từ đây có nằm
trong từ điển tiếng Việt phải không
bỏ qua việc tên có nhiều chữ đi mình sẽ
làm nó tệ Tên của ông có bao nhiêu chữ
cũng được mà người thật sự là
thì
mình đầu tiên là từ A đến Z viết hoa đầu
ngoặc sau đó thì ai ghét ý thường thôi
chả nặng thế không ạ Rồi bắt đầu của nó
là những này đi cho gọn
à à
Vì sao nó thì giả sử là nếu mình ông bắt
sâu người ông bắt sau giờ cậu là
à À ông kêu vào thêm vào trường hợp
nghiện 55 kìa đây Tok chó mèo
nghỉ mệt mấy ông cậu bắt sâu dưới kiểu
là từ điển tiếng Việt thì từ nào từ
nhiều nhất thì như chỉ có tôi đã sáu từ
thôi mấy ông sẽ là mi là một mắt là sáu
nhà anh được nó chắc cú chẳng hạn thế
nhớ tôi làm hai cậu đơn giản trước đi
Tôi vẫn làm hiệu tượng rất đơn giản cho
mấy ông đơn giản như này để cho ông ấy
Ông thêm nghĩa như thế này cũng được
hiểu thế thôi bỏ qua vụ đấy không tóc à
à nhưng mà sau đó là có dấu cắt đúng
không ạ cho một cách làm loạn sau đó lại
từ a đến z được ạ oke lại từ ai đấy
ông ạ nhưng sau đó thì lại có từ a đến z
nữa mà lại amis ét thì mất cả triệu
người na là Tôm nó rồi nó không ạ
ở mình cho đây hỏi chấm mà Thì đây sẽ là
sao nhé Sao thức Dạ
không Mi là không đúng không mắc cả Vô
Cực không ạ nhưng sau đó nữa lại lại dấu
cách nữa lại như này tiếp thì làm như là
đúng ạ
Tik Tok mình sẽ cho cả cụm này
trong mặt tròn rồi để cậu đó
thêm hỏi chấm 2 trần nhà là được
đúng ạ
Ừ ông hiểu tôi vừa làm cái gì mấy cái
loại hiểu mà
anh alo
à à
khi đó tôi vừa làm việc cậu bây giờ nhập
bao nhiêu tiền được đây em bị phong cách
làm cho anh số 10 tới nhà được à
Ừ đúng rồi
nhờ các cụ máy Tôi ôm cả dấu cách xong
nồi thêm nhé Miễn 5 ngày vẫn hợp lệ nó
thừa dấu cách ở cuối này ạ
a piece để xem Tại sao nó thưa dấu cách
ở cuối hợp lệ nhà hả môi thêm cái này cô
ấy đã quên đã
à à
ừ ừ
Ở
Đây Rồi Đây là cái cơ bản thôi vậy vẫn
chưa có bạn mấy ông thấy ta thì tắt được
hơn nhưng mà mình thế này đủ cơ bản thôi
không cần những nói tắt hơn qua đâu là
thứ khá không cần mắt thị trường hợp kỹ
quá
ở trường hợp này Thực ra nó nó sẽ nhập
được Long nữa sẽ không không thỏa mãn
đấy bởi vì đây dấu cộng này còn mấy mấy
ông muốn nó nhập Long vẫn được thì em
đổi nó thay nhà xấu xa thôi thì sẽ nhập
Long
ừ ừ
có thể nhập tên kiểu dài quá các tiểu
thư Thế thì cũng chết bằng cơm nữa thì
không có trường hợp tử kia đâu
ừ ừ
Ừ ok
Nói chung là nãy giờ đây toàn bộ kiến
thức giữa mới nếu ông nào biết qua lứa
cách cho cậu nhìn qua một lần rồi mà em
sẽ thấy cái này là con tương đối dễ hiểu
hơn một tí tiền hiểu mấy ông xem ở trên
mấy cái trang trại rách thì tôi khẳng
định là tôi dậy nó cơ bản hơn các bạn
hơn
thế nên là còn nếu mà Mấy ông mới hoàn
toàn công nhận cái này rất khó trong một
buổi tối thường anh dậy ở trên lớp phải
hai ba buổi gái cơ nên mày không được
ngạc nhiên thì mày cái này nó rất là khó
hiểu với chửi tượng như thế
Ừ nhưng mà nếu có thể Xem lại video mà
đúng ạ và sẽ làm lại như cái bài hôm nay
nữa nên là mấy ông làm dần thôi nó không
ạ
Đó đây là đầy đủ về đây cũng là đầy đủ
tôi những cái mà tôi có thể dạy xong với
ông về gái rồi bụng và buổi sau tôi sẽ
kết hợp ra Swift với lách để mà làm vai
đếch kiểm tra dữ liệu kiểm tra những cái
thứ người ta nhập đúng và nhập đúng sai
à Thế em bé Ông có về kiểm tra rất là
đơn giản không cần lại nỗi phức tạp như
nha à
Em xác bí mật à
à Tôn Bảo là cái bí mật về bạn Phương
Linh không nghỉ thì khi nào mà bạn phải
đạt được nó sẽ bật mí rồi chứ không phải
đến cuối buổi sẽ bật mí đâu ạ
Ừ hai cái link này tôi sẽ gửi cho bé
uống sau nhé Cái này nó rất hạ nó có đầy
đủ Có phải tại nó sẽ đầy đủ ấy
trong này nó cũng giải thích lại một lần
nữa này và mấy ông có thể dùng cái trang
react 101.com này mấy ông test thử cốt
các thử luôn để biết qua nhé án rồi quên
quên đấy tôi tôi nói thêm một cái nữa
thôi một cái nữa thôi về cái vụ mà nếu
để ý kĩ là ghét nó con thêm cái bạn thật
màn chất cái gái cái nó sẽ luôn viết nằm
trong cái cái
chỗ này
nó luôn nằm trong cái hay cái dấu này để
ghi cách một cái gì đó
và sau đó thì nó sẽ có thêm một vài ký
tự nữa Nếu bé ông đầy Chị ở đây nó cũng
ký tự nó là giờ và m thì thường nếu
không cần phải ghi Maria hay mở trong
trường hợp này bởi vì à Giờ đây sẽ hiểu
là nó sẽ trả về bạn trong trường hợp này
thì ông ghi Mg để mà thể mà nó sẽ trả về
thêm những cái khớp thay vì cái độc tiên
cái này để test thôi còn ngoài ngoài
thực tế ông dùng Viber thì ông sẽ không
dùng cái gờ ông ông bắt buộc phải chỉ có
một chỗ ở và chỗ để bắt buộc phải đúng
thì ông ấy sẽ thì ông không cần dùng cầu
làm gì cả con mờ làm chị để là
Ừ để mà hiểu là
để tách cái này ra hay nhiều dòng các
bạn dụng mơ thức a khi mà vai đấy chứ
các bạn chỉ có một dòng thôi không có
cơm màu và cái cái mà các bạn cần biết
nữa là cái y này mấy cái dưới này có thể
bỏ qua nhưng còn tệ y này
Ừ
đúng rồi trong đống này chỉ mỗi cái rồi
y incense típ tức à Không nhận cả tất cả
là bỏ qua Phân biệt hòa thượng đấy các
bạn sẽ biết về cái gì nữa nếu mà lần này
mà bực dùng người y này các bạn không
còn cần phải dùng ai Z viết hoa nữa các
bạn a z thôi là đủ rồi đây có mỗi những
cái đấy là những cái thêm của cái về
cách để không ạ
đó buổi hôm nay sẽ chỉ đến thế thôi à
I trở tình yêu muốn làm là đúng bài tập
này cũng đủ mệt rồi Cuối tuần mà thôi
chẳng yêu cầu vì khó ngồi làm lại đúng
ngay thôi à
à à
Ừ cái chào các bạn nha tạo như thế